if you want to hear how crypt series
such as look-see troubled youth
stoneheart and mordeo are all about to
collide then stick around to the end of
this video
[Music]
hello and welcome to horror history i'm
your teacher emo abraham lincoln in
today's lesson we've got a lot to cover
as we'll be going over the entire
timeline of events in the crypt tv
monster universe mordeo looksy sunny
family cult and so much more are a part
of this history we've got over 400 years
of lore to discuss this lesson is
sponsored by [ __ ] tv
the earliest known event takes place in
1609 when elk ridge falls is established
this is where the events of mordeo would
later take place in the late 1600s the
cursed statue seen in stoneheart is
created in new england during the witch
trial era
she came from up in new england
somewhere
some witch trial protector of women
nonsense in 1848 avon manor school is
established in the uk and would serve as
the setting for shelley nearly 200 years
later back in the united states though
two more towns are established one in
mohawk new york in 1853 and one
southeast farming town known as harbor
in 1876 which would later be terrorized
by crypt monsters like looksy a pony
walter and fluffy about 50 years later
the great economic depression hits the
united states and on march 20th 1930 in
new york city a banker named robert
capshaw kills his entire family upon the
closure of the bank created by him and
his brother the brother james capshaw is
forced to leave new york two years later
due to the financial situation and the
death of his youngest son and he moves
his family out to harbor which only
consists of some farmhouses at the time
he starts getting foreclosure notices at
the barn and since he's unable to let go
of his emotional attachment to his old
bank looksy goes after him however a
gang of thieves led by eventual youtuber
james janiece shows up at the same time
and gets to him first and looksie takes
one of them out as a warning not to get
in the way one by one looksie takes out
the thieves and the rest of capsha's
family each having some kind of
emotional attachment that they're unable
to release only two survivors are left
the cold-hearted leader of the thieves
and the young daughter who assists luxie
in completing a ritual to awaken a
second looksy monster i wouldn't be
surprised if the two luxies started
their own twin themed youtube channel
because that's the popular thing right
now isn't it nearly another 50 years go
by before the events of mordeo in 1979
it starts with a man who's turned into
the mordeo for eating flesh in the woods
what would follow is the first sighting
of a spell book known as the crypt tome
a man known as the butcher is in
possession of the tome and attempts to
summon mordeo by cutting off another
man's finger and eating the flesh on the
summoning ground he wants to be changed
into a monster but the queen mordeo
kills him because the flesh he ate was
not eaten out of desperation meanwhile a
newspaper headline from mohawk tells of
a continued search for the missing girl
scouts so mohawk and elkridge must be
somewhat close to each other the girls
stumble across the resurrection grounds
and the crypt tone but the mordeo queen
kills one of the girls causing the
remaining two to get into a fight one
girl bites the other as a form of
desperate self-defense and the other
girl slips and hits her head on a rock
she brings the tome to a desolate cabin
where she says she belongs to the mordeo
and starts to transform when the
transformation is complete she kills off
an injured man whose girlfriend takes
the book to try to lead her out of the
woods to escape the next morning she's
surrounded by several mordeo and
although she is able to make it out to
the road she's unable to escape their
wrath where the tome is once again
dropped youtuber bobby burns who
apparently was a part of the sunny
family cults in the 70s and 80s finds
the book which leads us to the era of
the cult's possession of the book
the cult emerges into the mainstream a
couple of years after finding the book
in 1982 the year a man peeing on the
side of the road is killed by two cult
members on april fool's day and a
crooked lawyer is stabbed many times and
dumped into a lake where the calling
card of the sunny family cult is found
the cults gained so much notoriety that
in 1994 two men named elias and roger
attempt to start up their own chapter of
the sunny family cult they capture a
scam artist who corrupted one of their
members and stab him to death elias and
roger create their mass as they began
recruiting new people in an isolated
location in the western united states
roger becomes obsessed with the crypto
inspired by the legends of suit the
birch a pony looksy and mordeo he reads
the prophecy that a girl of 17 with
violence etched into her soul at the
moment of her greatest weakness a blood
sacrifice of four victims and the fifth
will become something he has a vision of
the girl who tells him to find her
disagreements arise between elias and
roger on the values of the cults with
roger wanting to kill everyone involved
in the corrupt system and elias only
interested in snuffing out the sources
of the corruption elias and roger battle
for control of the cult and elias wins
roger backs down and continues to hang
around the colts for another year until
may 19 1995 when roger attacks someone
that elias refuses to kill and they
ultimately go their separate ways the
next tick on the crypt's timeline takes
place a couple of years later across the
pond at akton manor the brothers school
of avon manor where a girl named shelly
carter meets with her boyfriend oliver
greenwood at the border between the two
schools he gives her a bracelet one of
his final gestures to her before being
burned alive in some kind of chemical
storeroom and during science class his
teacher looked the other way tired of
oliver's constant misbehavior in class
the headmistress covers up the accident
not wanting the school to get bad press
when shelley realizes that her boyfriend
is missing she begins to snoop around
the school for clues realizing this the
headmistress takes action to ensure that
shelly does not find anything that she
shouldn't by hiring another student
heidi a girl who already dislikes
shelley to dispose of her if you squish
this bug for us
we can guarantee there will be a place
waiting for you
at willowdale england high school would
have been so much more interesting if
there were bounties on every student oh
wait i'm a teacher now i'm not supposed
to say that the following year on
graduation day in june 1998 shelley is
strangled by heidi and two other
classmates she watches helplessly as her
classmate celine is too afraid to stand
up to the bullies and shelly meets her
demise the incident is staged as a
suicide and they hang shelley's body on
stage during graduation
after parting ways with roger and
strengthening his own chapter of the
sunny family cult elias got married and
moved to a small iowa town known as
bettendorf around the time of the new
millennium they gave birth to their
first and only daughter and named her
taylor they kept their lives as cult
leaders a secret from their daughter for
as long as they could about six years
before she snuck downstairs and
witnessed one of the rituals apparently
they had not heard of baby monitors
her parents tell her to keep the rituals
a secret but taylor becomes more and
more interested in the activities of the
cult over the years as this gradually
happened while taylor continued to grow
up an incident occurred in the small new
york town of mohawk in the year 2007 in
a certain house a mohawk man beats up on
his wife before going outside to have a
smoke he hears a girl's laughter in the
distance and after being out there for
some time his wife comes out to check on
him and discovers his decapitated head
it's another five years or so before the
next interesting development with
elias's daughter taylor the cult
discovers that a copycat member of the
cult has killed a child in town this
marks the first time that taylor has
attempted to take an active part in the
operations of the cult against her
parents wishes she sets out to expose
the copycats putting herself in danger
before eventually being rescued by the
cult and facing her father's fury
i'm going to tell you this one time and
you are gonna listen you don't ever
ever
do that again
this whole thing
everything that we have in our it's me
you don't change the plan you don't say
a word unless i tell you to
the town of harbor has developed into a
much more populated community since the
birth of the second looksy in the 30s
now the town has attracted a new monster
the santa claus-like demonic creature
known as walter who eats children who
are awake past midnight on christmas eve
in 2012 walter commits what is assumed
to be the first of a string of child
disappearances on christmas eve the
episode is titled walter's revenge and
while it's unclear what this little girl
actually did to him to warrant revenge
it must have been pretty bad because he
eats her alive
[Music]
her sister delaney is a witness to this
midnight snack and would spend the next
six years plotting a revenge of her own
a revenge on the revenge
can we call that a re-revenge but before
that would happen there's a week where
three crypt monster stories all take
place at once in harbor they are season
one of looksie troubled youth and season
two of stoneheart let's start with
looksie who rises again after 13
students at harbor high are killed via
poison this causes luxie to come after
many of the parents and family members
mourning the children who died who are
unable to release their emotional ties
luxie forces the assumed killer to do
his bidding by leaving notes for all of
the other victims one of these victims
reads her notes on the door of a
bathroom stall because we have really
terrible public restrooms here in
america and while she's unable to
release her love for her separated
husband she's somehow able to survive
the attack leaving her in the hospital
with two broken legs looksie appears to
her again in the form of the husband but
this time she's able to fight back and
drive the creature away leaving her
physically broken and emotionally dead
not long after looksie forces her to
write the notes for its future victims
meanwhile at a nearby school called
journey high a wolf-like creature runs
amok killing several students with the
assistance of her master a cheerleader
named eva not long after that a second
incident takes place at a local library
where it's revealed that this other girl
has the ability to transform into the
monster and while all of this is going
on because this town is really having a
bad week a girl named rebecca inherits
the power of an ancient witch named a
pony the power takes over her whenever
she's in the presence of abusive people
and she uses it to kill her alcoholic
father she starts attending a support
group for the abused as she meets each
member a pony helps her take out all of
the toxic people in their lives one day
the two goth sisters follow her home and
witness a pony's power when rebecca
beats up three guys who gang up on her
the sisters become obsessed with her
powers an attempt on two separate
occasions to ambush rebecca and try to
learn the powers secrets little does she
know the group was just a facade the
group leader and the goth sisters are in
league with you guessed it the sunny
family cult in order to try to transfer
rebecca's power to one of them at the
end of the season they appear to have
succeeded in stealing the power of a
pony
the last reported sunny killing was in
2015 in the northern iowa town of
bettendorf
this is the last sunny family cult
incident to be reported in the news but
that doesn't mean that they aren't
active in 2016. taylor goes on a date
with a college boy at age 16 where they
sneak into a swimming pool and she lures
him into a shed where she's supposed to
kill him in front of her parents as a
cult initiation but she's unable to go
through with it her father is upset with
her so to make up for it she invites
four of her friends over telling them
her parents aren't home the friends come
over and play truth or dare but hang
with me this is much better than that
one movie taylor is dared to do seven
minutes in heaven with one of the boys
but when time runs out she's the only
one who comes out alive she cuts the
power and kills the other girl that
they're hanging out with then she stabs
the other girl's boyfriend she tells the
last boy that she likes him and invites
him to join the cult he refuses so she
kills him as well that week is the last
week of school taylor makes a new friend
named jaina taylor starts feeling
regretful about what she's done and
invents in her diary she finally meets
roger who's posing as a substitute
teacher at her school in order to keep
an eye on her he would later come after
taylor and jaina with an axe while
they're sneaking around the school after
hours in order to scare taylor into
believing that her family could be in
danger taylor jaina and her boyfriend
lance celebrate taylor's 17th birthday
as she struggles between normalcy and
her life in the cult as they're all
leaving roger kills jaina's boyfriend
and leaves the sunny family cult calling
card along with his body in the woods
the stage is set for roger to change his
story on the girls pretending to be a
police officer investigating the killer
taylor connects this to the man who came
after her at the school thinking that
roger has a chance to catch this man but
not knowing that it was actually roger
trying to trick her he tells taylor that
she might be in danger and wants to take
her in for questioning but instead
kidnaps her and drives her across the
country to a motel in the california
desert they arrive there on may 21st
roger kills two tourists and the motel
manager he introduces taylor to the
crypt tome which is still in his
possession he tells her that he believes
that she is the girl of 17 who will give
him the power to transform as described
in the book taylor is able to call her
father for help but she's also starting
to have some strange visions at one
point taylor has a vision of every crypt
monster to date and they're all
connected to this ritual that roger's
trying to carry out her father shows up
to save her but becomes the fourth blood
sacrifice in doing so in retaliation
taylor gives roger what he wants by
killing him fulfilling the text written
in the book the fifth will become
something and beginning his
transformation at some point after this
the cryptome is given to this mysterious
man and taken to the uk we're yet to
find out exactly how this happened but
one can assume that roger just had no
more use for the book
there are a few crypt series that don't
have exact dates associated with them
there's the door in the woods which sees
the unleashing of this monster who
murders the entire town except for one
girl who loses her arm as she seals away
the monster once again this appears to
take place in the past but this may just
be a society that's rejected technology
because the monster the brutes also
appears in hospice the story of a
haunted hospital wing which seems to
take place a couple years before present
day the birch only has a single episode
out but it looks to be a more or less
modern day and the plot is about the
summoning of a forest dwelling
protective creature suit is a grim
reaper-like monster who reclaims the
lives of those who escape to death in a
modern setting i believe all of these
take place before the events of mohawk
which looks to take place around april
or may of 2018. at the very least we
know that school is in session and it's
warm out remember way back earlier in
this video if you're even paying
attention when i mentioned the man who
was decapitated by the ghost girl in
2007 well in 2018 a new family moves
into that same house after the father is
fired from his job in new york after
getting too handsy with his nursing
staff the family struggles to adapt to
the small town and the son who's
regarded as a freak by nearly everyone
in the story has these visions of ghosts
that inhabit the town the ghosts began
to attack his older sister killing her
and hanging her up in the front yard on
their second night in town upon
discovering this the dad loses it and
goes after the sun proclaiming that he
should have been the one to die that's
when the ghost of the girl from 2007
starts messing with the father before
ultimately completely tearing him apart
with her chains the mother runs into the
street to try to get help only to be
ignored by everyone in town who are
somehow being monitored by these little
packs with red blinking whites before
the mother is able to escape the town
she too is run down by the ghost the
fate of the sun is still unknown
the modern day events of shelley can't
take place long after that as those take
place 20 years after shelley's death at
the avon manor high school reunion
shelley comes back to life and with the
assistance of celine exacts her revenge
on the three high school bullies
responsible for her death she saves
heidi the girl hired to assassinate her
for last and hangs her body before the
entire school reunion having gotten what
she wanted from celine shelley turns on
her to get revenge for how she turned a
blind eye to the three bullies all those
years ago shelley cuts off celine's hand
and takes back the bracelet given to her
by her boyfriend she takes it to the man
with the crypt's tome who uses some kind
of spell to power it up again the
school's administrators throw their best
man to try to cut down shelley and
prevent any more damage but she defeats
him and she's able to successfully
resurrect oliver together shelley and
oliver do away with the rest of the
corrupt administration thus completing
their mission for now what shelley
doesn't realize is that the strange man
with the crypt tome hits her and selene
against each other celine comes to
shelly's family home disguised as
shelley who's been dead for over 20
years now and kills her sister and
mother before setting fire to the house
the man who powered up shelley's
bracelet is behind it and he likely
wants to fuel shelley's rage in order to
motivate her to do more of his bidding
our last story takes us once again back
to harbor for christmas eve 2018. six
years have passed since delaney watched
walter kill her sister and she's been
plotting ever since about how she can
exact her re-revenge she invites her
middle school friends over and together
they develop a plan to capture walter
using human baits and the holiday
decorations set up around the house they
successfully capture walter but
foolishly leave him alone to untie
himself while waiting for someone to
come pick up the body and dispose of it
come on delaney you were this close when
you're dealing with walter you gotta
wish him a merry christmas and a happy
new year walter gets out and attacks one
if not all of them at some point he
escapes and goes on to devour another
little girl at another house i think the
interesting thing about these crypt
monsters that sets them apart from one
another is that each one represents
something those of you who watched the
previous episode of horror history
probably recognized mordeo as tripp's
interpretation of a wendigo which warns
against the taboo of cannibalism shelley
is all about karma that which you do to
others will come back to you looksie
represents lingering feelings and
regrets a pony is all about the power to
stand up for oneself against abuse and
trauma and the sunny family cult focuses
on the themes of individuality and
finding your own path fighting for your
own values this does not mark the end of
the crypt monster universe though far
from it there are new entries into the
crypto lore being uploaded fridays on
crypt tv and coming in may a new series
fights night where crypt monsters will
be facing off against humans in epic
cage matches so make sure you subscribe
to their channel as they continue to
fill in some of the missing gaps on this
timeline and i'll see you in the next
one assuming we both survive